who are we
what are the dominance the power we
wield
it wears away at our very being
it breaks us
it unmakes us
that its immaculate aspect might reveal
itself
the icon
there's going to be another war isn't
there
every day we delay brings us closer to
disaster we must move now
[Applause]
the chaos he would wreak would sweep all
of valasthir into the abyss
[Music]
i unite the dominance that we may bring
an end to the strife
and found a new order to see us unto
tomorrow
if i take the field
our dew will shake the island
to its foundations
so
[Music]
there will be losses it is true
yet for every citizen who falls
another can be bred
for every home that burns another can be
built
the empire will live on
[Music]
awaken child of fate
awaken
everything
[Music]
when you go looking for strength
it's not like a game
this journey doesn't have a real ending
okay then hope you're ready to begin
if you want to start off on the right
foot in this city hit the streets
never feel loose and when i get up in
the game yeah i'll be improving a real
problem but i solve them on face proof
and if you think i'm gonna fold it you
talk
[ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
i got it
[Music]
[Applause]
let me have some fun ready then show me
street fighter 6.
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
take a look outside
did you know that they call callisto the
dead moon
dead
just like you would have been if i
hadn't fished you out of that wreck
so whatever you're holding on to right
there
that's your old life
you gotta let that go
because
your new
life
is entirely
in my hands
i'm just trying to give you a chance
at rebirth
[Music]
[Music]
i just love that last part
gives me chills every time
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
located baby eagle
[Music]
good
i guess you me
picked the wrong spot to vacation eh
[Music]
you will receive our most sacred body
it begins
now
if i could just forget what happened
that night
the pain
even for a second
this time
it can be different
it has to
[Music]
so
[Music]
oh
[Music]
3.
[Music]
these past few years
sacrificing so much and
asking for nothing if you want to change
the world
you have to be the kind of man
who can make the hardest decisions
do you really need two of those you are
everything that's wrong with this city
i'm gonna go uh
do your thing
you can't just push people around like
that
just ask for help next time time to
bring back the glory days
[Music]
[Music]
did you just leave your clothes on the
kitchen floor
ah